[Music]
as sports betting grows
states tackle
teenage
problem gambling
with online and retail sports betting
now legal in more than 30 states the
portrait of a new
problem gambler is emerging the high
school student although the legal age
for gambling is 18 to 21 depending on
the state between 60 and 80 percent of
high school students report having
gambled
for money
in the past year according to the
national council on problem gambling the
group says the pandemic and easy access
to online gambling have heightened risks
for young adults four to six percent of
high schoolers are considered addicted
to gambling the group says the
percentage of high school students with
a gambling problem is double that of
adults research has found
and as sports betting becomes pervasive
in brick and mortar betting parlors and
often for anyone with a cell phone state
gambling addiction services are
underfunded kids who have problems
fall through the cracks says the person
doing the
doing the study
so uh it's a problem oh four to six
percent that just
blows my mind and breaks my heart
well uh sports betting
the advertising budget for it is
astronomical obviously we've seen caesar
and all the other super bowl ads that
are running and adds running around this
stuff pushing pushing pushing pushing
pushing
and um
it's all based on a cool factor
you know fanduel it's it's you're cool
if you're sports betting because you're
up on sports and you're a player you
know
and so uh mix
those things with being a high school
student and you have a disaster on your
hands
and parents that don't know what the
flip your kids are doing online
what in the world mom and dad
so well i can't monitor everything then
then don't let them i mean oh my gosh
well this younger generation seems to
have such a
um
a drive and a curiosity around money
which in many senses is good if they're
wanting to join the ramsey plan and do
investing the right way but we see so
many kids getting involved with crypto
and this and it's just like there's so
much confusion it's like if we can
channel that desire to learn about money
and invest and build wealth into really
stable methods that's awesome but this
well what you've got is people who are
emotionally immature they're teenagers
they're physically immature they're
teenagers their brains aren't fully
developed
and you've got a an entire generation
that has never known a day without a
cell phone
without a connection to the internet
that it's all it's existed and been
prevalent in their lives their entire
lives so it's very normalized
and then mix in the highly addictive
addictive behavior of gambling oh and
mix in ease of access and anonymity and
the ability to do it in secret
in a deceptive way
uh and you have a real recipe for
disaster here yeah so what would you say
a parent should do if they find out that
their kid is involved with this
well here's the thing we do know
the uh we work with
people who have financial problems in
portions of our business not all of our
business but we work with wealthy people
and we work with people with financial
problems we know that personal finance
is 80 behavior
we also when we see the problems um we
know this 100
of addicts
have financial trouble
eventually
100
um
because it screws up your life it
becomes your god and it sucks all the
the actual available financial resources
out of your life and channels them
towards this destructive behavior the
fastest so we deal with ethics all the
time that's what i'm saying we're not
specialists in helping people with
addictions but we deal with addicts all
the time because of their money stuff
and so we watch these behaviors the
fastest growing addiction in north
america right now by far is online porn
it is over the top
online pornography now makes more
total revenue in america than all
professional sporting events combined
football
nascar
baseball basketball
add it all up it doesn't even make it it
doesn't even come close to online porn
it is
blowing up and guess who else that's
affecting the same exact age group okay
it's affecting everyone but this same
exact age group and all kinds of data on
the problems that that presents
the second fastest growing addiction in
north america
gambling
see you think you think when you say
addiction you think of alcohol cocaine
crack
whatever and they're all there the old
classic addictions are still around
without a doubt
but there are no but they're not online
accessible
and these online accessible addictions
are the ones that have scaled
and are sneaky and they sneak into
people's lives
and they're easy to ha easier to hide
until they're not
until it blows up and they go everywhere
with you but i have on your pocket i
have a friend of mine who has a kid
that's in his 30s
and the kid uh
you know
he's like four hundred thousand dollars
in that on the sports betting
oh my god before they figured out what's
going on he's losing everything he's
lost his job he's probably going to lose
his little wife
she's about had it you know and he's
destroyed his life but he got sucked
into these things and he called me up
and he's like can you help me i'm like
well yeah i can help but you're not
gonna like the
solutions because my solutions are
pretty brutal because it's a pretty
brutal situation
so we're gonna treat him like he's a
freaking addict because baby he is an
addict and 100 of addicts go broke 100
are manipulative and 100 lie
and so it's a it's a brutal business to
get in the get in the dust with those
folk yeah and help them to help them to
love them well
it requires a tremendous amount of
courage and strength on their part and
the people that are helping them
so this is so dangerous it's
unbelievable what would i do uh i would
just shut down the internet you know
there'd just be no access there'd be no
cell phones
um you have a you you know it would be
like okay what would i do to a 16 year
old who was um
uh
you know caught driving a car with
cocaine in the trunk
i'd take away the car if the law didn't
i would i'd be done okay you can't you
can't apparently you don't get that
these things don't go together uh you
don't get to have one
and uh because i love you so much i'm
going to bar you from access to things
that are going to kill you
and whether it's a vehicle or a cell
phone
or online presence or avatar or whatever
it is i cut out of your dadgum life
because i love you so much because you
is out of control puppy you know and
that's that's what
man
and that is love even though your your
kid may not feel it in the moment they
may they won't feel it very upset in the
moment that's that's love that's very
loving
but it's not the problem is it's a
little difficult to tell your kid not
the sports bet when you are
it's a little difficult to you know tell
your kid not to do crack when you are
um
and you know well yeah i know what my
dad does i know what my mom does you
know
it's a little difficult
and so because you know rachel always
says more is caught than taught so if
you're working running a life that's
character based and isn't tied into this
garbage then you're you can ease it's
more easily then
it's it's easier for you to take a
stance and go
i just love you too much let you kill
yourself
i'm not gonna do it because i'm still
your parent i'm still in charge
as long as you're 16 years old you live
in my house i can take you out and make
another one looks just like you you know
we're not doing this
we're not going to live this way
that's old-school parenting i understand
some of you people think that your
children have freedom they don't they're
children your is your job to protect
them from everything including
themselves and some of your parents are
wishes
you're complete wishes and you've got to
stand up and just go no cell phones i
mean we're talking about cell phones in
general at the break and you got little
babies and you're going what am i going
to do when my kids get to this age yeah
oh man
yeah i was talking to somebody recently
and they were talking about how their
third grader was the only one without a
cell phone and i was like
i thought we had at least till middle
school till we had to deal with that
nope
yeah so i mean these things are
the phone in and of itself is not evil
but it is a gateway to evil
and so if you can't keep the gate shut
then uh we'll just not let you hang
around the gate
that's a pretty simple thing but this is
dangerous stuff right here and really
these companies these sports betting
companies it's on them too because they
got nothing in there to keep you from
doing it they got no blockers at all
and so somebody's going to end up with a
class-action lawsuit shutting old caesar
down
if they don't quit screwing around with
these kids this is the ramsey show